hey guys dr. Berg here I want to talk
about what you must know if you don't
have a goal butter okay people are told
they don't need the gallbladder it's an
unnecessary organ and you won't have any
problems but there's some long-term
effects first of all what is the
gallbladder okay it's a little sac that
hangs underneath your liver but the size
of a little potato and there's a tube
that comes from your litter and this
little sac that hangs off this tube all
right but the key is what it holds what
it stores the gallbladder stores and
holds bile okay b.i le1 is my hell bile
is the very important fluid that helps
you absorb fats absorb fatty soluble
vitamins regulate cholesterol help
balance hormones so it does a lot it
helps lubricate the colon okay so we'll
talk about all those but basically
without a gallbladder you don't have the
concentrated effect normally the bile is
concentrated by five times the amount in
that little sac there so we need that
bile to secrete out when you eat fats to
be able to pull it in so without that
gall butter you're always going to be
deficient in Aisle okay it's just gonna
trickle down because it's made by the
liver it's gonna trickle down and by the
way bile is what prevents golf stones so
probably the reason why you had a
gallstone in the first place is you
don't have enough oil so no they take
the gallbladder out and you don't have
the bile you just you continue to have
other problems okay so let's take a look
at without a goal but all the potential
issues number one you're not going to
balance the cholesterol anymore
cholesterol is necessary in the building
of hormones specifically stress hormones
okay but other hormones too like
testosterone they're they're made from
cholesterol your brain needs cluster on
the nerves need cholesterol so
also free cholesterol needs mile to help
break it down so you can have more of a
buildup of cholesterol without bile so
we have an imbalance of cholesterol the
good and bad okay that's number one
there were two you may find that you're
not actually eliminating toxins why
because all the toxins go through this
bile duct when they come and they're
eliminated so the bile helps in the
breakdown of toxins and the elimination
of toxins not to mention the lubrication
of the colon so you may end up with
constipation okay
now the next one is thyroid t4 the
inactive thyroid hormone is converted to
t3 through the liver and the gallbladder
so without a gallbladder your thyroid
can suffer in that it won't convert so
you might end up with a thyroid issue
which affects a whole host of problems
because we need that gallbladder to do
the conversion okay so the other one is
preventing fighting liver because the
fat can actually build up in the liver
if you don't have the bile bile breaks
down fat now if you don't have the fat
soluble vitamins vitamin A the vision
suffers you won't be able to see at
night when you're driving in the dark
the vision just kind of goes down with
either you need vitamin A in general for
your vision okay the skin becomes dry
you have issues with skin the inner skin
and the inner sinuses become a problem
sinus problems sleep apnea immune system
that's on vitamin a vitamin D is the
regulation of calcium so you may find
that your calcium is off especially the
metabolism of calcium you get bone pain
you have issues with the immune system
things like that and then also when
people are low in vitamin D they have
problems with depression during the
winter time because they don't have
enough vitamin D vitamin D is also good
to prevent asthma as well okay vitamin E
very essential for the heart
vitamin E increases the oxygen to the
heart by two and a 250 times I'm sorry
two hundred fifty percent so it actually
increases oxygen to the heart to prevent
heart cramps it's great as an anti
angina nutrient vitamin E is also
the anti sterility so it prevents the
incoming sterile it helps fertility
vitamin e is important in the skin so
many women use it on their skin vitamin
E oil but I know we got vitamin K one
that's prevent bruising and clumb and to
help clotting vitamin k2 prevents the
soft tissue calcium from building up and
the arteries and the joints very very
important
there's even certain final nutrients
like plant-based chemicals in like the
cruciferous vegetables that are fat
soluble too like we have Luca pain
lutein carotenoids those are all fats
Seibel those are all very very important
in protecting the eye protecting against
macular degeneration just helping you
see in general so those are fats ival so
and then also you you're not going to
absorb the omega-3 fatty acids like
think about what why you need omega-3
fatty acids that's all anti-inflammatory
I mean its precursors to build body
tissue so many issues so these are just
a small list of potential issues and you
could have if you don't have gobbler
okay so I hope that gave you some
enlightenment the question is what do
you do if you don't have bumbler well
what I would recommend is to take some
type of bile support to supplement your
body so when you eat you have in a file
to prevent these issues but you have to
realize that it's going to be a slow
process it doesn't happen overnight so
you may see symptoms months after the
gallbladders removed all right alright
thanks for watching i'll see in the next
videos